Brad Pitt for once upon a time no show
Brad sent co-star Margot Robbie to pick
up his Best Supporting Actor Award
Brad couldn't be here tonight due to
family obligations he starts by saying
hey Britain heard she just became single
welcome to the club
wishing you the best with the divorce
settlement blah blah blah
besides Brad's brexit joke he also had a
little fun with Meg's it oh and he says
that he is gonna name this Harry cuz he
is really excited about bringing it back
to the states with him William and Kate
laughed at that one but rebel Wilson
joke not so much it is really great to
be here had the Royal Anjou up Royal
Harry
nice yeah this royal palace play William
is president of the BAFTAs and showed
his own sense of humor I must admit I
don't know whether I should be proud or
slightly alarmed about the number of
winners over the last decade who
betrayed members of my own family
Renee Zellweger Renee won Best Actress
for Judy and had this reunion with her
Bridget Jones co-star Hugh Grant
Joaquin Phoenix received Best Actor and
a Laura Dern won Best Supporting Actress
afterwards the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge mingled with the winners on
stage
Kate's Alexander McQueen dress was
recycled she warned eight years ago
during an overseas visit back in 2012
both ScarJo and Renee were pretty in
pink scarlet in a feathered Versace
number and Renee who wore a shimmery
prada outfit that also gave off pastel
vibes Charlize Theron s magenta
strapless Dior dress featured a thin
black belt around her waist and a
pleated skirt and there are a number of
ladies in black from Margot Robbie's
lacy dress that showed off her back to
Emilia Clarke sequined slip dress
Saoirse Ronan gon was made from recycled
fabric black also seemed to be the trend
at the Netflix afterparty
Charlie's change into a pantsuit with
lace underneath while scar Jo donned a
black mini Laura Dern celebrated her win
with Powell Bradley Cooper and Robert De
Niro
[Music]